yesterday morning we heard from the
foreign secretary who was saying that
that very much was still the right
option the localized targeted approach
that the government had been talking so
much about
but now as you say whitehall sources
saying that there have been
conversations at the highest level the
prime minister the chancellor the health
secretary michael gove talking
about whether there should be tougher
restrictions across
the board in england that could come
into force as soon as next week this
hasn't been confirmed yet
by number 10 we don't know exactly what
this would look like would this mean a
higher tier restrictions perhaps a tier
4
or a lockdown similar to the lockdown we
saw last time round
but clearly this is a marked shift in
direction as you say
um the government were clear that they
wanted to try to tread this
middle path between helping the health
and the economy of the country
they already are facing a lot of
pushback from some backbenchers who feel
that already they're going
too far and we are hearing some
grumblings this morning that
um backbenchers won't be happy if um
this is indeed
right and we do hear that the government
will be going further
on a national level in england um but as
i say you know it's been it's been an
interesting week we've seen europe
moving in a different direction
france and germany shifting to a more
national approach we're halfway through
the whale
circuit breaker and all the while the
scientific warnings are mounting
yesterday
we had the new sage documents you heard
there from our health correspondents
suggesting
that we are past where we should be in
terms of the worst case scenario in
terms of the
spread of the virus so concerning
scientific warnings and labor of course
saying that all of this shows we should
have gone
with their idea of a national circuit
breaker sooner
and if the government wants to act it
needs to do it very fast